proteger los intereses nacionales y de
su gente Este es el objetivo principal
de la invasión rusa Ucrania a decir del
presidente Vladimir Putin sin embargo el
mandatario ratificó la disposición de
sentarse a la mesa de conversaciones
estamos preparados para negociar
soluciones aceptables con todas las
partes implicadas en el proceso es cosa
suya no somos nosotros los que nos
negamos a negociar son ellos no es la
primera vez que el presidente se refiere
al diálogo en lo que va de semana en
otra ocasión subrayó que todos los
conflictos terminan en la mesa de
negociaciones y que Moscú no renunciaba
a ello sin embargo condicionó a lo que
calificó de soluciones aceptables
sabemos
lo que dice con frecuencia no está
acostumbrado que alguien cuestiona lo
que él está diciendo y en este momento
yo creo que no tenemos una respuesta
Clara cuál pueden ser estos condiciones
Rusia ha perdido el terreno en Ucrania a
pesar que fue
Rusia declaró estos territorios como
parte de su territorio nuevamente pero
básicamente yo creo que debemos esperar
que van a aparecer mayores detalles por
ahora no está muy claro Cuáles van a ser
estas condiciones en este sentido la
guerra continúa en bahmud objetivo del
kremlin desde hace semanas Los
bombardeos Invasores no cesan
pensé que este sábado se viviría un
ambiente festivo pero de ninguna manera
ya que todos los días estamos lidiando
con el sufrimiento de las personas sabes
y eso tiene sus consecuencias
los enfrentamientos también prosiguen en
allí 13 asentamientos fueron afectados
por los ataques de las fuerzas del
kremlin el conflicto cumplió este 24 de
diciembre 10 meses de acciones
ininterrumpidas sin una posibilidad
visible del cese de los ataques